can we explain who darf
is i just if i drink too much it's just
my favorite of england's alter ego
do you remember who you do you remember
when you're darf i always usually wake
up in the morning i'm like hey everybody
how's it going and they're like how dare
you show your face here
like what what what what then they
started [ __ ]
listing [ __ ] off like this like you did
this this this
there wasn't enough hours to do that
like how was i that busy
very busy dude yeah dave england gets
drunk to the point where he becomes his
alter ego darf
and like nothing good happens with yeah
i don't do it much because i remember i
remember was it was at 2.5 when tremaine
was talking about how
you know darth came out and then the
next day they had you like jumping off
of a hor or
yeah yeah yeah so was that before the
shot off the horse first three that was
three three
yeah so that was so that was way yeah
yeah that was like early in three and
then dave was like uh
like i didn't drink for the rest of that
whole movie and then for another three
years
like three years three years what was it
what was a terrible darth
episode like was it tremaine's wedding
or bam's wedding
oh bam's wedding and he went through the
hotel just breaking everything i broke a
lot of stuff i guess that's what i was
told
april was so disappointed that was the
worst part for me is
april's disappointment where was this in
and you found the hotel somewhere yeah
maybe philadelphia or something what
what what do you drink that makes you
turn into darf
uh alcohol of any sort but you know no
more
whiskey or tequila really does the trick
yeah does the trick any alcohol that
gets you can like
quickly like like the beer's taking me
so long to drink finally i'm like ah
phooey i give up
yeah but that the hard outcome you're
like this is the wow it's going down
easier and easier and easier wow i don't
know
yeah nothing nothing to be proud of
that's for sure
but it's made some people laugh people
seem to laugh when they tell the stories
but at the time nobody's laughing
yeah dude that's so [ __ ] good man
he wakes up no idea that anything was
wrong how dare you
i mean you must have had mornings like
that too steve right where you're like
yeah what's your alter ego
i mean i i had the time
when uh we were in russia and i got so
[ __ ] that we got so wasted on vodka
and part of the night like was me
kissing pontius on the dick you don't
remember that no i do remember that
and then i suppose like uh i don't
remember anything
maybe later but the next morning i came
out of this little
bungalow cottage thing and there's
he looks at me just with disgust
absolute [ __ ] disgust he says
do you know what you did last night and
all of a sudden my heart just [ __ ]
stops and i'm like
oh my god i'm about to hear like i just
did something so
[ __ ] terrible oh no oh no what is it
what is it he goes
you're a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you're [ __ ] mad at me for kissing
the dick that's so funny dude
but you do you and i said oh dude is
that all sweet
yeah [ __ ] man that's so good i mean were
you a blackout drinker or did you just
do
too much cocaine to where you were just
up yeah
i didn't black out too did you ever wake
up in jail or like you knew you were
going to jail
oh i thought dude what a creepy thought
i don't think i've always known i was
going to jail
guess what i have the number 30 ranked
hot sauce on all of amazon
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole and
order yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon and buy stevo's hot sauce for
your
butthole yeah
yeah dude